right class settle down Dyke stop
playing the clown and distracting the
was Malone right 25 times in your
homework book I must not interrupt in
class even if I think it is about the
will Hersh is there the remotest
possibility you might care to join the
rest of us and stop daydreaming looking
out of the window imagining the collapse
of Nelson's column this week saw the
start of SATs tests nationwide and one
poor head teacher was rebuked by the
boss of Ofsted for wishing pupils good
luck and checking they filled out for
the tests it risked stressing out the
ten-year-olds what class Cobblers
courtesy of millenials snowflakes
Generation Z we've already bread enough
spineless bed-wetters who can't say boo
to a chick so long as they are carefully
implemented and pupils don't think the
life of the family pet rests on the
results these tests are a necessary part
of growing up they're going to have to
face pressure at some point shortly and
on that point Dyke continued this latin
verb a mo a mass a Matt Dyke I was
looking for a mamas amatis amant ok I I
think we make a big mistake in trying to
shield kids from stress and anxiety
because as you said they're going to
face it the minute they go out into the
outside world anyway III think children
are capable of extraordinary things I
think they're born with a potential for
greatness and that's why I don't think
we should be wrapping them in cotton
wool you know we can't protect them from
stress but what we can do is equip them
to deal with it and I think one of the
greatest tools you can you can give to a
child is resilience you can teach them
because resilience makes mix them mix
them brave it makes them curious that
makes them trust their instance it means
they don't fear falling short of
expectations and even if they do fall
short of expectations it means that they
can actually just if if they fail the
test they will bounce back
Andrew cities and and and I and that's
why I totally agree so this I think they
have we have to we have to teach them
how to deal with this chance you know
kids aren't born with resilience they
don't all have it but they can be taught
it it can be built within them inaudible
isn't there a danger that these SATs I
don't know what they were we never had
them we know but so whatever they are
their exams I take it there's some tests
in English and in maths they're taking
place this week typically each paper is
somewhere in the region of between 25 45
to 60 minutes long is it there a danger
that where we are producing kids that
are encouraged to learn by rote and then
pass these exams through memory tests
and by rote and then what we're doing in
the end and I suspect some of our
societal troubles to put it mildly today
may be reflected by this we're producing
people that rather than knowing how to
think critically simply have succeeded
through memorization great I I can
eleven plus generation you know I passed
it up in placer long ways I think 38 out
of 42 in my class why did we all do so
where the average would have been 20 why
don't we do some work because we had one
teacher yeah who did nothing else but
for a whole term may take old 11 plus
tests now is that education that
actually would seems to me it's not why
coming down ended up I come into this
from asking about teachers you see it
seems to me that there's quite an
interesting stat here from you guys who
asked teachers are they concerned about
their well-being because of the tests
and then 96% said they were and then
they ask them do they think SATs now as
the curriculum and 93% said they do so
it seems to me while it's obviously you
want to know can kids had kids learned
properly it can they believe I can do
all those things if it means that it's
so distorts education that actually it's
damaging the kids then I'm not sure it
does bring up let's bring up one because
my sense as I was introducing this
conversation somehow lost your support
i-i-i think you're both wrong about this
you know Carol I think I agree with your
spirit of what you're saying that
children shouldn't underestimate them
you know children often do have
incredible talents they are very
resilient I don't think that's what this
is about this is actually about bringing
out the best in children and no teachers
think that SATs are giving them the
opportunity to thrive and because they
need to be let me just let you hear what
the general secretary of the National
Association of had teachers has to say
he said in reality SATs do not tell
teachers or parents anything they didn't
already know about their child or school
but have got negative unintended
consequences of distracting from
teaching and learning and narrowing the
focus of the curriculum and either this
is my issue that I don't think we should
be wrapping kids in Causton well I think
it's important for them to do things
that are hard to experience failure and
learn how to bounce back but this is
about narrowing their education just
like you were saying so there's this
obsession on very stressful tests that
reward one kind of intelligence the
ability to memorize and wrote learn but
exams per se exams generally the latest
research says that exams health children
learn rather than hamro save
implementation it should just be another
regular day so if the kids are getting
stressed Greg and I take on board the
percentage 0.96 and 92
that speaks to the way the teachers are
allowing that you it should just be
another Tuesday in school or another
Winston that's the problem is the
treatment it's not going to be if you're
judging the schools any stressing the
teachers it's not because you're
stressing everybody now cares how did
your getting judged and it's just
another Thursday in school Nick are you
ready go on up these are questions from
a real life that's to go right first
question
Niccolo sure are oh there's the first oh
yeah go on
gone on Wednesday Felix has a dental
appointment what is the adverbial in
that Vincent sorry on what on Wednesday
Felix has a dental appointment what is
the adverbial in that sentence winstead
lucky Wednesday
thank you second question all for me yes
what is the possessive pronoun in this
sentence the boy showed me around the
school he took me to the music room and
pointed out which class three was his
his Goods
number three a square number and a prime
number have a total of twenty-two what
are the two numbers a square number and
a 11 and 9 well listen you were lucky
like the first can I just can I can i
I'm sure if all say yes to this can I
bring Jeremy Corwin into this this is
beyond this at Primary School in
particular children need the space and
the freedom to let their imaginations
roam instead at the ages of just 7 and
11 we put them through unnecessary
pressure of national exams now based
upon the questions you could just solve
and that does look like unnecessary
pressure I mean that those last maths
questions I mean now the point he makes
about imagination I think is the point
that I was trying to make earlier that
you made up for as well as that actually
the type of intelligence is the phrase
you used at that age there's a certain
type of intelligence I think should be
encouraged which is the freedom to
imagine and to and to create and to roam
because that's what kids are developing
at that stage I'm not so sure that
focusing on the logical type of ones you
must agree we have a little judged you
were judged by the jobseeker
I dub uncheck author by the listen it's
over you yeah you're judging me I
remember the 11 plus and the kids who
failed
it devastated yeah I felt for years and
years yeah I remember my oldest brother
who failed stood at the top of the
school top of our road cuz he got up to
get his some results from the school and
shouted the rings of the vote I failed I
don't want to do that to kids at that
I'm not it's not the kids brick it's the
teenagers no it's not you re gonna judge
teachers I think we abandoned our
teachers that's the problem in a band we
abandoned trusting the teachers to say
yeah this kid needs some help or this
kidney
that we actually said we've got it we've
got a legitimize all this suit through
an exam system that tells us who fails
can I distribute very quickly and say
that I failed my 11 plus and it had the
opposite effect on me I thought I looked
at the people who passin for Amma smart
is you and it made me work extra hard
which is what I'm talking about
resilience and bouncing back